[Music]
welcome back to off the record and we've
got don in the hot seat today
[Applause]
okay hottie is the uh we got the hottest
seat in the world with even hotter
questions where we literally just gonna
bombard you with questions you just
gotta answer them right just be as
truthful as possible everybody can tell
us who's a liar here but we're gonna
start it off real cool and cold prepare
to declassify every file in your brain
declassify it and bart's gonna start it
off real cool and look lukewarm and then
we'll build up the heat all right all
right let's do a lukewarm question dude
if you had to pick one for the rest of
your life one way if you had to pick one
for the rest of your life
would it be a pogo stick
or skip it jesus dude you're saying oh
pogo sticks like why i'll never skip it
because it's you can travel further
on the distance you can use it as a tool
if
there was a unicycle
in the form of a pogo stick would you
write it
legitimately
can you explain that
imagine a unicycle right
and then you sit on the unicycle and
it's a stick make sure you know which
way the stick's pointing by the way
and then you bounce you bounce all the
flesh colored unicycle
no
[Laughter]
currently in a relationship i am okay so
i'm not gonna ask too many weird
questions about relationships that was
for me that was a censoring for me thing
wow alliance how long have you been
together
uh about two years
is she subscribed all subscribed i hope
so i i have a question okay so so a
follow-up to that is so like
you know um
you do a lot of macho [ __ ] right and
this is what i noticed it's pretty funny
right so like you come from a place
where bullets are flying at you you're a
soldier all this stuff
did you have when you came back to the
civilian world
did you have a nervous feeling when you
came up and talked to women 100 yeah
right because i noticed that like
they'll be like crazy fighters and like
all these like dudes that are like doing
macho [ __ ] and then when it comes to
like girls they're like [ __ ] they're
back in junior high mode and like i
don't know what to do what am i gonna
say because they only know how to flirt
with dudes they know how to flirt with
death is what i'm saying i'm talking
about oh i like that joe wow that's
correct but it's a different it's a
different uh feeling right it's like a
different world completely were you were
you in a relationship while you were uh
in
is that where afghanistan
were
what was your most recent deployment uh
to the philippines to the philippines
and you were in a relationship during
then
um
this last one no
i mean my most recent one though so
2017. and then in afghanistan you also
were in a relationship i was in a
relationship you were yeah
how did you have sex
did you write sex through papers like
what was the
horniest
horniest
or
most romantic
thing you've done like have you just um
on an envelope send it or you ever send
her she has sent you panties
send panties when you got some panties
in the mail dude it's like
what about in the letter did they write
a sex story yeah the right set did you
go yes and then put on her panties
or does your commanding officer like
take it and like read it first and then
like give it to you no they won't do
that what does she say what like what
are some of the things that you're like
got you going good
i can't wait to rip off or i can't wait
for you to rip off these panties off of
me
oh
that's pretty tight and she sent them to
you he's quite the author she's quite
the obvious you guys you guys do you
guys over there like you know
share things like that
yeah we talk about we don't know i'm
going to share like like oh man nick's
mad lonely hey dude just sniff this
panties
my first appointment to iraq my uh
cousins sent me a fleshlight
that's a good gift though do you know
what a dark knight is
did you pass it around
your turd dude yeah for a fee
you know what i mean for a few years
you were a fleshlight there it was a
fleshlight potter dog you wearing
[Laughter]
your flashlight was during a deployment
yeah which interact or what was your
go-to place to use the fleshlight oh
yeah dude you don't have much options
you know that bit big i was talking
about like with 30 dudes sleeping in it
and then you had uh like a
wood shack a poor john that you took a
[ __ ] in so it's one of those damn so
when you're jacking off with
um you know like your platoon or or your
squad right you got your unit there
everyone's in but without the boys
in the the
bay with people yeah so when there's
people there right a part of me
if i was there this is you know i'd i'd
actually be self-conscious about
man am i going to come too quick because
i don't want my boys around
you know i don't want the boy i don't
want them to be like yo joe you come
quick started he just came i think i
would like act out a little bit are they
gonna so then people be like damn joe
jack's off a long time huh because i
need to i don't know my pride would be
hurt a little bit like do you have you
considered that like you want people to
go damn joe went at it all night long
he's the marathon i guess you gotta look
at the rest of platoon and if like six
or seven people have like really as long
as you outlast them yeah you're like in
the clear because sometimes i do that
when i'm like when i'm pissing right and
i'm like oh this is one of those p's
where i thought i had to pee but i don't
gotta pee that much but the guy next to
me is peeing for a long time now i don't
want to be a [ __ ] two-second pee guy
i'm gonna stand here like i'm still
peeing
i thought that was just me man thank you
for sharing it bro so that's how i would
feel if i'm
be a man
i'm not jacking off and i'm like yeah i
want to finish right now but like
damn it's only everybody's like 30
seconds and [ __ ] they're timing me right
now dude but i bet you're trying to rush
though you're trying to get that [ __ ]
over with kind of yeah yeah you don't
want to you want to be you don't want to
miss the mission
man you know what's the nastiest
uh
jackoff thing that you did over there
that that only makes sense over there
like you would never do here oh probably
all of it but don't you need jacking off
in a platoon of 30 people in one bed
that's one of them yeah that's one of
them okay so other than that
did you like like [ __ ] let's jump off
together or like you know
i love dawn's face right now dude
let's show her hands
let's do hands so it feels like it's a
different person you know i'm so used to
myself i know this is just entertaining
but i still feel comfortable
double dutch rudder it's where you hold
the guy's hand like what's the no it's
like when i'm holding my dick you're
holding your dick and i'm grabbing your
biceps
what's the nastiest thing that you've
done i don't know it should probably
probably
share porn i don't know man it gets
dude
are you guys watching are you guys using
imagination you guys use a spanking oh
we have a um we had a hard drive and
everybody was sharing it and we didn't
have laptops over at the time so
everybody was using an iv pod with a
screen oh [ __ ] it's like one with a
little circle thing on it what do you do
you you what did you scroll up and down
i was like hey i'm done pass it to the
next guy so it's like passing around a
playboy but on an ipod yeah he's pretty
high tech yeah that's pretty tight
though actually he put the headphones
into headphones in and everything full
blast so you said like you know um even
before the military right like you
always were able to perform under
pressure right um and then you think
after the military like having bullets
fly around you you feel like you can
perform even better now under pressure i
would say depends what type of pressure
because um people could feel social
pressure people could feel fear people
could feel sexual pressures so like an
environment it depends on how you how
you view it and how you kind of react to
it so so okay so like let's say
something that does give you pressure
like i don't know like being in a
business meeting or something that
you're not familiar with right
um
how do you deal with it when you feel
that
nervousness or like oh [ __ ] my emotions
are taken over and i can't think clear
first i think it's like hey this is a
first world problem i'm not getting shot
at i'm not you know i'm not gonna about
to die and then the next one is just
just breathe you know i do a lot of
breath work
bring the exercise to kind of help you
put you in the right mental state so i'm
gonna get personal okay because this
applies to me
when you feel petty
and you wanna [ __ ] demolish the [ __ ]
of some somebody who maybe offended you
right like crossed you maybe a middle
age to an older white dude in a business
meeting who you just want to destroy
because of the way he spoke to you or a
random asian kid at jj's hong kong cafe
true
shout out's not a random asian kid man
that's why undercuts are illegal okay
for this young man yes
but um
but yeah like let's say it's like you're
like you know that that pity moment
takes over right and you're just like
man i don't be petty right now and i
want to talk some [ __ ] but it's not
professional
um
what do you do in that point like do you
like how do you stay stoic without being
like
i'm just gonna [ __ ] go for it well
you gotta remember the reason why you're
in that situation that's good advice
yeah
that's a really good advice yeah cause
like hey are you there to make a
business deal to not lose 20 grand a
month yeah or are you there to [ __ ]
be petty and talk [ __ ] to some white guy
today's video is brought to you by
audible you know these days
i like to listen to um things to kind of
help me improve because i feel like when
we first started jk and barbell like i
would study a bunch right and then you
use those tools and then you would
implement it and then i feel like oh man
i feel like i reached my plateau or my
ceiling on the next know-how so i need
to get more know-how in my brain and i
love audible because i have a ton of
audiobooks and my favorite part about
that is especially when the author is
the same person speaking oh that's not
bad because you can hear the emotions
yeah you could hear their like speech
cadence and it feels like they're
talking directly to you and especially
like on these long drives i'm just
driving i could either listen to booty
shaking for four hours or i could
actually learn and increase my brain
powers i like booty shaking too it
increases my penis powers yeah but
learning sometimes is a lot better
because you can grow from that even
though the other way you can grow down
there but then the point i'm trying to
make here is that audible is pretty
awesome and they have podcasts they have
stories they have all kinds of cool
things so much content to check out and
if you're a new member you get 30 days
free which is amazing and i highly
recommend you check it out because if
you don't like it there's nothing that's
going to cost you you know you just like
i don't really like it does it for me
and that's completely cool but if that
interests you go check it out go to
audible.com off the record or text off
the record to 500 500 that's audible.com
off the record or text off the record to
500 500. so so exactly compromise the
objective i got what i wanted right so a
mission accomplished every single point
mission accomplished
now the ptsd of it is i'm replaying my
mind and going oh but i wish i did it
this way do you ever go through that
so it's like mission accomplished
everybody has regrets and like hey i
could have done this better i couldn't
then this better but
you can't change anything in the past
you got to take the experiences that you
learned and like the lessons learned
from that experience then apply it to
the next one but you really can't that's
so good i was hoping you would give me
revenge techniques but god damn we got
the 11 minute mark of the video this is
where we like to turn up the heat a
little bit so we're going to walk you
through the water you ready for this i'm
going to ask you i'm back i'm asking
honest question i'm asking it's not true
though honest question you don't have to
answer them even though it's hot
you ever kill anybody
yes
what was that like your first time
i mean
it depends on what kind of situation
you're in right are you getting shot at
are you just defending your friends are
you i'm just i'm just asking you about
your situation the first time yeah your
first time
yeah it was uh
i mean like most of the firefights over
there are gunfights so that you're 100
to 300 meters away so if you get a
gunfight you know all your homies are
gonna be there to back you up and
they're also gonna be in the gunfight
that's what they live for so like when
someone dies on the road on the corner
of it like are you the guy that killed
them maybe maybe not are you the guy
that killed it so it's just chaotic and
and it's far away you just don't know
where if you actually got it confirmed
or not i mean yeah exactly i wasn't a
sniper so like they were going to tell
me like hey you got that
one shot one kill kind of
situation for that you know i'm also
like dropping bombs when you drop a bomb
like you're
killing
whatever is in that area you know and
sometimes we have the ability to go over
there and and check if our effects were
what we wanted to be sometimes we didn't
i wouldn't yeah that's true because i
wasn't even considering the fact that
like okay when i think of this i'm
thinking of a very personal like
you're breaking into like a compound
right like a swat team and then you're
coming in and you're eliminating someone
that's like maybe 10 feet away but then
your job was actually calling in a a
drone or some kind of deployment was
like we definitely kicked in doors were
in the house you know and we were in
that situation as well but
um so that's why i'm saying it depends
on what kind of situation how you feel
about it the closer the closer you are
of course
like the more impacted you are by
because you see it like firsthand
so in that situation it's a little bit
different which is the one that impacted
you the most in either good or bad way i
mean there's definitely situations i'm
definitely not proud of of the things
that have happened over there of course
those are the ones that impacted me a
lot heavier than i guess it's still
like haunted till this day yeah for sure
is it um so i wasn't listening to a
rogan was it that guy dakota
i coded myers yeah um but there was one
where it was like oh it wasn't marcus
the truth i forgot but one of them
was saying they were in a man-to-man
situation both have no more rounds
and it was literally
i win or human so he had like a rock in
his hand
and just pounding the head right
and it's like he says at that split
moment when you're looking eye to eye
that's really when you just see the
humanity in people where both people
just want to survive but they know only
one person's making it out that's
that's intense it's like that's holy
[ __ ] it it's got to be me you know and
the other and you could see like that
person and you know that in their eyes
and it was just like um
like really really intense did you ever
experience something like that uh thank
god i've never been into a hand-to-hand
combat situation i can only imagine what
that would be like but
that'd be crazy because that makes it so
personal right with just blunt objects
that's so primal versus like
like let's say like uh if you're a guy
just doing drone strikes
it still affects them but then it's so
it's a little bit removed a little bit
it's not as real yeah like it is real
but it's it's also very uh like you're
looking at a computer screen you know
yeah but i also like to caveat is that
like
the trauma that a person a drone pilot
goes through or the per the trauma that
maybe like marcus whoever dakota miser
was could be the same exact level to
them yeah yeah that's true you know so
everyone's different so it's like hard
to challenge like oh you haven't been
through [ __ ] and all that stuff people
like in the military and the veterans
community is kind of like that which is
shitty
but it shouldn't be like that you know
i'd be like you went through your own
[ __ ] i went through my own [ __ ] and yeah
we're still what was the situation that
was the craziest to you probably can't
talk about that one
yeah but um
yeah
was there was every moment when you were
out there that you
didn't believe in what you were doing
but you still had to go forward with it
i would say like when you're in that
situation where you're on deployment
you're so sucked into the situation
that's going around you your environment
is your world right because you don't
have much communications back at home so
like you're if you're getting shot at
like that's your world like yeah i don't
want to get shot at i want to go home to
my family so i'm going to focus on not
getting shot or killing the guys that
are
trying to shoot me or my friends and
that becomes your world yeah so it's not
like uh
i don't want to do this anymore it comes
a little bit of survival a little bit of
joy a little bit of excitement when you
know you gotta do cool things so it's
like a mixture of that kind of tunnel
vision in a way it's 100 yeah no knowing
all the stuff that you've been through
if you have a kid and they go i want to
be a raider like you pops would you
say do it i would let him decide
on whatever he wants to do in life for
sure but i would give him the
information that he needed to to
understand um a little bit about what
he's about to go through so that way he
can prepare a little bit more so he can
go into the situation not being
blindsided by all that were you
blindsided as a raider or did you know
what you're going to get yourself into i
think i was definitely
blindsided in the right way where like
it was like a rude awakening for me to
stop stealing clothes or whatever i was
doing at the time and getting into the
military then i got a taste of the
adrenaline and that kind of
lifestyle then i wanted more of it i
wanted a more professional environment i
wanted to do cooler things with the
skills and i believe that i had the
skills to do that so so like your first
deployment um when you're just with your
like regular unit were you infantry or
whatever so like
that
kind of i guess
work is different from special ops work
right like it's like one is like super
crazy dangerous job versus the other one
is like more like me would not say it's
any more dangerous depends on the area
that you're at depends on the enemy that
you're fighting at the time
but the difference for me the huge
difference was in a regular infantry
unit you were very reactive to the
things that you was happening around you
so we got shot at we shoot back we get
shot out we try to chase these guys down
you know
and in the special operations we were
hunting these guys we're actively
collecting information to figure out
where they live where they sleep where
they eat and then we
do our jobs in that manner so it's like
ninja assassin unit versus like you know
guards
or something but like the assets that
you have in a special operation scene
you have a lot of intelligence at like
assets in infantry like you have maybe a
helicopter that flies by once every
three days that could look at something
for you
did you feel safer in the normal
infantry unit versus special ops no i
felt a lot safer
in a really bad area with special
operations because of the resources yeah
because like oh you're the first one to
get if you call like what they call a
tick so like troops in contact like
you're getting air asset in afghanistan
probably in like 10 minutes so if you
could survive for 10 minutes you got
bombs coming you got guns coming you got
air ships coming to to come save your
ass have you ever i think we're gonna
yeah have you ever been a situation
where you're like oh [ __ ] we're all
gonna get wiped out like and then they
come to rescue you and it's like a movie
and you're like you can't but
i personally have never been in that
situation i've always been on the better
side of the fight yeah um and
i would like to say that it's because my
team planned our missions well where we
were so no black hawk down type of
situation we definitely had a marine
helicopter uh crashed right outside of
our base and it took like a three-day
fire fight to get that thing and the
ordnance and then back in were you part
of the firefight for three days yes it
was holy [ __ ] and then was how long was
did you guys plan for the mission we
didn't plan for it the helicopter was
taken off from our camp after uh picking
up some guys or whatever it is and on
the way out it got shot and it crashed
like 300 meters outside of our base
and then are you guys close to supplies
and stuff we were just on our base
on our base so he had to go and try to
rescue like at three o'clock in the
morning we went out picked up the pilots
and everything like that but uh we
started getting shot at so we had to
leave all the hellfires or all the
rockets the missiles inside the
helicopter and then there's also
crypto which is the um like the secret
key to for communications on side that
helicopter that the way we communicate
so oh i thought you guys used bitcoin i
was like god damn
different they have i mean crypto in the
helicopter yeah it's a crypto
photography
you know so but we have so we had to
either destroy it which they didn't want
they wanted us to retrieve all the
missiles because they [ __ ] ton of money
so in order to get that helicopter and
everything back in it was like a
three-day gun fight to get back and
they're just awake for three days no we
rotated uh pushed out depending on where
we were and then uh after the second day
we've been awake for two days we had
another team that came out and helped us
so you had to salvage it piece by piece
back to the base we literally just
hooked two big like uh military tow
trucks on it dragged it as far as we can
behind cover and then while under fire
though holy [ __ ] you have to put the
hooks on while under fire yeah
oh yeah
on on a brighter note um
what's the moment back to the ipod porn
is what he's saying
military career
uh what's like the most gi joe [ __ ]
where you're like [ __ ] yeah this is why
i joined like was there like it could be
in training it could be you know
deployment but is there one where like
either helicopter go run over the ocean
and you have fins on like what was like
that moment that you're like [ __ ] yeah
this is why i joined this [ __ ] uh i mean
i think like on my second and last
appointment we're in the philippines
with um this navy um
squadron with h
hsc 85 is like the special operations of
the navy for pilots
but we flew around and we literally look
we're like shooting sniper rifles in the
philippines and we flew over manila
coming back in and like just kind of
that surreal and your feet's hanging out
of the helicopter yeah you're like dude
this is [ __ ] i feel like bruce willis
right [ __ ] sick you know like that
that i'm stillness to this day like and
that was more that was straight like
when you're shooting a helicopter was
that training training we're just
training yet
sick hey thank you for sharing man
thanks man thank you for your service
man yeah thank you for your service yeah
for real yeah that's crazy that's
[ __ ] so cool i can't believe we know
a marine raider yeah at least you went
over to war versus you know just
yes
no i don't doubt it but you know this
will wrote something on goddamn day i
gotta get one in you know second place
this guy right
i gotta sweep the warehouse dude getting
dirty in there
[Music]
you